enforcement is taking place at the state
level 41 attorneys general are demanding
information and documents from
prescription opioid manufacturers or
distributors the Pennsylvania Attorney
General is part of that investigation
he says 13 people die every day in his
state from drug addiction DeMarco Morgan
is in Williamsport Pennsylvania outside
the university of pittsburgh medical
center in Susquehanna DeMarco good
morning good morning earlier this year
the emergency room right here behind me
saw an average of two to three overdose
patients per day the family of one
victim who died last year says more
needs to be done to show just how
destructive opioid addiction can be
there is no training no preparing for
losing a son the death of fatiah spur
key is ingrained in the minds of his
parents Todd and Dorie the 22 year old
became addicted to prescription
painkillers in 2015 he died from a
heroin overdose the next year I woke up
here my wife screamed 6:30 in the
morning
you know Thad wake up dad wake up and
then you know emergency responders
arrived said that there was no one they
can do for our son we had no idea how
addictive turning to heroin was I no
idea like we do now we do know
Pennsylvania reported more than four and
a half thousand fatal drug overdoses in
2016
that same year more than 7 million
opioid prescription drugs were dispensed
throughout the state
his addiction did not define who he was
after watching 60 minutes on Sunday Todd
says he's outraged at how Congress
lobbyists and the drug distribution
industry have responded to the nation's
opioid epidemic what do you want to say
to Congress I would like to have Trump
here and ask him to talk to Congress to
Senate and to reverse that bill
I might just tell them about our son and
what were those words be I don't know
but it's not an easy road if there are
things that are hindering the war on
drugs then they need
a fundraiser in memory of phat raised
more than three thousand dollars for a
wrestling scholarship at the local high
school and a substance abuse program
Nora
DeMarco thank you so much it's such a
troubling story